officers down in front of the bank  automatic weapons being fired  [Music]  you want to drive or cannot drive  bank robbery suspects have taken an  ambulance  i got a cop shot just got to get him to  the hospital we're doing hostages now  i came to you for a loan you're my  brother have i ever gotten you anything  that i couldn't get you out of lock  everything down  we're just trying to get home  we don't get to walk off into the sunset  i have a plan  police are following these two suspects  got to chill out  gotta chill out hit me up  what's going on in there  these guys are nut jobs right here it is  [Applause]  [Music]  does your wife know your rap eggs  [Music]  i'm sorry brother i think it's the best  of me  sorry that brought you into this  i just wanted things to be the way they  used to be we are trying to save you  [Music]  i'm gonna get you back home little  brother  [Music]  and get everybody home  only in theaters april 8.  [Music]  you